well rishi sunak and sadi javid may have
been the best known and most senior
figures to resign from boris johnson's
government but they are not alone the
party's vice chair bim afalami andrew
morrison who was a trade envoy and three
parliamentary private secretaries the
lowest rung of government jonathan
gullis sucky butty and nicola richard
have all quit a swathe of the prime
minister's cabinet though has said it
will still support him including figures
like the foreign secretary liz truss
home secretary pretty patel nadine doris
and dominic rob
so is that support enough to help boris
johnson survive our deputy political
editor sam coats reports now on a pm
under pressure and on the brink
this is what loyalty used to look like
these two men now leading the efforts to
oust boris johnson
a drive that's intensified tonight but
has not so far succeeded despite a raft
of resignations the prime minister
remains in number 10 rebels now hope he
will not be in there for long well i
think he's lost the uh support of most
of the conservative party it's very
difficult to find a conservative mp who
privately
supports him and i think it's inevitable
that he will be gone
sooner rather than later the exact
timing who knows
if he won't resign then it'll be up to
the party to force him out do you think
that boris johnson will be gone before
recess if i was a betting man i'm not
but i think it's more likely they'll be
gone than not gone
removing the prime minister will not be
easy current party rules mean he's safe
from a leadership challenge for another
year but that could change if rebels
take control of rewriting those rules
we've got the 1922 they'll announce
tomorrow
the rules of the timetable for elections
to the executive
i think we'll have an executive elected
now who will be pro rule chains change
and whatever the cabinet do we will be
changing i think we'll be changing the
rules before summer recess
to remove the prime minister have a
second confidence vote within 12 months
this is the most dangerous moment of the
prime minister's political career not
parties that brought him here but the
disastrous handling of chris pincher's
resignation it's remarkable that the
departure of somebody few had heard of
from a job not many know about could
engulf the government in a crisis of
this scale but despite those cabinet
resignations it's not clear that's
enough
to get boris johnson out of office to do
so
more than half of the conservative
parliamentary party need to decide they
want a change of prime minister
rebel tories appealing to their
colleagues to take action we can't go on
like this
and i think that's going to be a matter
for all of my colleagues those in
government and those on the back benches
about what steps we now need to take to
deal with it over the last 72 hours
change things are more people putting in
letters more steps being taken to our
spores
i don't know whether they they are but i
think what's happened over the last few
days will have changed people's opinions
these are very serious matters they
don't appear to have been handled
properly at the beginning
and the way they're being handled now i
think is uh signs of a downing street
that isn't properly run
another difficult day will dawn for
boris johnson tomorrow to our grilling
by a committee of mps on integrity in
the rule of law as well as prime
minister's questions opponents in front
of him now with even more enemies behind
him samcote sky news westminster